[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sallyis
Welt ich stehe gerade auf unserer
Baustelle und zwar um genau zu sein in
meiner zukünftigen Küche okay jetzt
sieht man noch nicht so viel davon also
die Wände sind hochgezogen hier kommt
ein Fenster rein der Boden ist gemacht
aber allzu viel kann man noch nicht
erahnen aber im Prinzip muss ich mich
jetzt schon um die Planung meiner Küche
kümmern zum einen um eine optimale Küche
dann zu bekommen um optimal planen zu
können auch damit alles rechtzeitig
ankommt und zum anderen auch um Kosten
zu sparen das heißt ich muss jetzt im
Prinzip schon wissen wo kommt das
Spülbecken hin wo wird der Backofen sein
um dann die Anschlüsse richtig legen zu
lassen bereits jetzt im rohau ich zeige
euch das jetzt einfach hier mal im
Hintergrund hier seht ihr z.B den
Abfluss denn die Abflüsse sind ganz
besonders wichtig die kann man jetzt
nicht im Nachhinein noch mal reinlegen
oder es wäre halt eben sehr schwierig
deswegen haben wir die jetzt schon
reingeplant und ich erzähle euch einfach
gleich ein bisschen was über die Küche
aber dazu gehen wir ins Warme denn mir
ist es hier doch ein bisschen noch zu
kalt ja jetzt sind wir hier bei mir in
der Küche die Küche spielt natürlich bei
mir eine sehr zentrale Rolle ich koche
hier nicht nur sondern verbringe auch so
sehr viel Zeit mit meiner Familie und
mit meinen Kindern hier und natürlich
arbeite ich auch hier das heißt ich
drehe hier auch meine Videos für meinen
YouTube-Kanal und für euch und für eine
normale Küche für einen normalen
Haushalt ist die Küche natürlich sehr
groß auch für eine Großfamilie aber für
meine Bedürfnisse jetzt gerade mit den
Youtube Videos ist s ein bisschen zu
klein das heißt wenn ich hier drehe dann
stehen hier überall hinter euch also
hinter der Kamera die ganzen Stative
herum die Kameras die Lichter der Ton
überall auf dem Boden ist Equipment
verteilt und es geht zwar also es ging
ja auch die letzten drei Jahre aber
natürlich ist es für mich ein bisschen
unpraktisch weil z.B diese Ella die
kleine einfach nicht dabei sein kann sie
hat gerade ihre aktive Phase und
krabbelt jetzt nicht mehr herum sondern
sie klettert dann schon in der Küche
herum möchte dann auf die Stative auf
die Kameras und eben auch aufs Licht und
da ist einfach eine große
Verletzungsgefahr und deswegen darf sie
momentan einfach nicht dabei sein wenn
wir hier drehen weil sie sich einfach
verletzen könnte und bei Samira ist es
beispielsweise so wenn sie Besuch
bekommen von ihren Freundinnen dann ist
es auch sehr unpraktisch weil Samira
natürlich auch gerne mal in die Küche
rennt und ihre Freundin mitbringt aber
ich kann da einfach nicht
fremde Kinder sozusagen vor die Kamera
mitnehmen und muss dann natürlich immer
aufpassen und die Kinder sind dann
einfach beim spelen sehr beschränkt das
heißt ich habe dann hier meinen Drehtag
und die Kids sind z.B bei der Oma Samira
darf hier mit dabei sein aber es ist
natürlich ein bisschen unpraktisch für
meine neue Küche wünsche ich mir
deswegen dass die Lichter z.B an der
Decke installiert sind denn ansonsten
stehen die Lichter so wie hier jetzt
beispielsweise in der Ecke herum und
jetzt für den Dreh geht's natürlich
heute abend müssen wir dann wieder alles
abbauen weil jetzt morgen z.B kein
Rezept Drehtag ist das heißt ich möchte
am Abend dann natürlich gerne dass es
hier nicht mehr nach Studio aussieht
sondern wieder nach mein Meer privaten
Küche und möchte dann eben auch mit
meiner Familie einfach auf dem Sofa
sitzen auf dem Fußboden spielen ohne
jetzt drauf achten zu müssen dass Ella
hierher kommt und dieses Stativ hier
einfach umhaut und sich dabei z.B
verletzt wenn wir aber z.B einen
rezepttag haben und am nächsten Tag auch
filmen dann spar ich mir einfach den Auf
und Abbau und wir lassen alles stehen
und dann ist es aber ziemlich blöd für
mich weil wir dann einfach wirklich im
Wohnzimmer sitzen im Esszimmer sitzen
und dann einfach auch nicht abschalten
können weil einfach ständig die Arbeit
vor unseren Augen ist und hier ein
einfach alles auch voll steht und es
stört uns einfach auch selber und
deswegen wird es in unserem neuen Haus
so sein dass ich einfach zwei Küchen
habe das heißt eine Küche ist für mich
und für meine Familie privat da muss ich
dann auch gar keine Kompromisse eingehen
sondern kann die Küche auch so gestalten
wie ich möchte und die andere Küche wird
dann praktisch meine youtube-küche ist
ja natürlich auch meine Küche die wird
dann ein bisschen großzügiger sein und
einfach so dass ich wirklich Licht und
Ton und wirklich alles einfach
optimieren kann das heißt die Lichter
hängen dann an der Decke der Ton ist
optimiert ich habe hint eben auch Matte
Küchenschränke und in meiner privaten
Küche kann ich dann praktisch alles so
gestalten wie ich das möchte
hier im Moment in der jetzigen Küche war
es ja auch so dass ich Kompromisse
eingehen musste also die Küche ist war
so sehr schön aber es war jetzt nicht
meine Traumküche also ich musste z.B
hier im Hintergrund die Matten Fronten
nehmen damit z.B die Lichter dann nicht
zurückstrahlen und dann in die Kamera
scheinen und auch allgemein muss ich
einfach so ein paar Dinge beachten um
eben jetzt für die Videos alles zu
optimieren und deswegen haben wir jetzt
für uns beschlossen dass es einfach für
unser Familienleben und auch für den
Arbeitsalltag besser ist wenn ich
einfach zwei Küchen habe das heißt die
eine Küche für uns ganz privat für unser
Familienleben und die andere Küche die
so optimiert ist dass ich eben meine
Youtube Videos drehen kann wo aber die
Kinder trotzdem dabei sein können weil
einfach das Kameraequipment und die
Stative jetzt nicht malr hier herum
stehen sondern einfach festinstalliert
sind und ich so keine Verletzungsgefahr
habe und außerdem kann ich die Küche
etwas nutzen weil sie ein bisschen
großzügiger ist um z.B auch mal
Veranstaltungen zu machen oder kleine
Kurse zu machen und es wird ja jetzt in
meinem privaten Wohnzimmer einfach nicht
gehen und die dritte Küche die wir
planen werden das ist eine Küche für
meine Mama denn meine Eltern die werden
demnächst dann eben auch mit uns wohnen
und da freue ich mich auch schon richtig
drauf und ihr müsst euch das so
vorstellen meine Eltern die waren bisher
immer für mich da die haben mich in
allem unterstützt was ich gemacht habe
und sie haben mir nie Steine in den Weg
gelegt das heißt immer wenn ich gesagt
habe Mensch mama Papa ich möchte jetzt
einen YouTube-Kanal machen z.B haben sie
nie gesagt das schaffst du nicht sondern
sie haben immer gesagt Mensch mach das
und wobei können wir dich unterstützen
und ich denke jetzt ist es an der Zeit
für mich danke zu sagen und zu sagen
okay ich hole jetzt meine Eltern zu mir
mit ins Haus sie bekommen dann eine
eigene Wohnung und meine Mama bekommt
jetzt endlich eine eigene Küche und
meine Eltern die waren bisher immer so
sie haben fünf Kinder großgezogen und
haben praktisch ihre eigenen Bedürfnisse
immer zurückgesteckt und immer alles für
die Kinder gemacht und uns unterstützt
und ich denke meine Mama hat wirklich
verdient auch mal eine neue Küche zu
bekommen und da wird's dann einfach so
sein dass sie eine ein bisschen größere
Küche bekommt als jetzt denn jetzt müsst
ihr euch vorstellen ich zeige euch jetzt
hier mal die Küche meiner Mama ist
wirklich eine ganz kleine Küche so wie
es einfach früher gebaut war das heißt
in den 70er Jahren das Haus ist jetzt
auch schon über 35 Jahre alt und es ist
eine etwas längliche Küche aber wir
haben hier trotzdem Platz gefunden zu
sipt also meine Eltern und meine vier
Geschwister und saßen hier am Esstisch
und haben auch zusammen gegessen und
auch heute sind wir gerne noch dort mit
Murat und mit den Kindern aber wenn
natürlich die ganze Familie
zusammenkommt müssen wir natürlich auf
den Gr Esstisch im Flur ausweichen aber
mir ist es einfach ganz wichtig dass
meine Mama Platz bekommt um in der Küche
gut arbeiten zu können aber momentan ist
Ihre Küche einfach so dass sie zu wenig
Arbeitsfläche hat das heißt sie
verbringt sehr viel Zeit damit um z.B
Produkte von A nach B zu räumen und von
B wieder zurück nach a sie hat keine
Abstellfläche und muss einfach immer
schauen wie organisiert sie ihren
Kochalltag und wie kann sie es schaffen
einfach weniger Arbeit zu haben und es
ist einfach so dass die Küche eben nicht
so optimal ist das heißt die Geräte sind
sind zwar super die sind wirklich okay
aber die Platzierung der Geräte ist ein
bisschen falsch das heißt es ist einfach
nicht strukturiert und organisiert und
auch die Küchenschränke sind eben nicht
so dass es ihr den Arbeitsalltag
erleichtert und ich möchte ganz gerne
für meine Mama dass sie eben eine Küche
bekommt die eben auch zu Ihren
Bedürfnissen passt das heißt da kommen
jetzt keine hightechgäte rein das
braucht sie nämlich auch gar nicht weil
sie einfach schon seit über 40 50 Jahren
schon so kocht wie Sie es gewohnt ist
und auch sehr gut kocht muss ich dazu
sagen und sie soll im Prinzip einfach
eine Funktion ale Küche bekommen wo dann
einfach viel Platz ist für sie aber auch
nicht zu viel dass er einfach nicht viel
putzen muss und im Prinzip alles auf Sie
abgestimmt ist jetzt wisst ihr also
warum ich drei Küchen benötige eine
Küche ist dann für meine Mama eine Küche
für mich privat für mich und meine
Familie und eine Küche in der ich dann
arbeiten kann und dann die Youtube
Videos eben drehen kann die jetzige
Küche die ist jetzt schon fast 3 Jahre
alt wirklich der Hammer wie schnell die
Zeit vergeht und ich habe auch damals
schon ein Video über die Küche gedreht
weil ihr danach gefragt hattet aber ich
muss auch dazu sagen ich habe damals
schon ein paar Bedenken geäußert und die
haben sich leider bestätigt ich zeige
euch das jetzt einfach mal an gewissen
Punkten hier bei dieser hertplatte z.B
hatte ich die Bedenken weil die
hertplatte auf der Arbeitsplatte auflegt
aber außenrum jetzt nicht irgendwie noch
ein Rahmen ist dass es eben passieren
kann dass sie springt das heißt wenn ich
jetzt mit einem festen Gegenstand
dagegen komme habe ich schon damals
überlegt da geht doch bestimmt die
Glasplatte kaputt und leider ist es auch
so passiert dass die Herdplatte wirklich
an mehreren Stellen schon gesprungen ist
und da einfach ähm das Glas weg
gebrochen ist und es ist natürlich nicht
nur hässlich sondern ist auch natürlich
auch eine Verletzungsgefahr weil ich
jetzt immer aufpassen muss dass die da
nicht dran geht dass dieser Mira nicht
dran geht und dass ich mich selbst auch
nicht verletze wenn ich hier die
hertplatte Putze was mich aber am
meisten gestört hat ist dass einfach
hier dieser Spalt ist wo sich immer der
Dreck festsetzen kann der Schmutz die
Krümel und dann muss ich das hier alles
mit einem Zahnstocher rausholen aber
dabei passiert eben auch dass ich die
Dichtung drunter verletze und deswegen
ist es nicht ganz so optimal also das
werde ich auf jeden Fall anders machen
beim nächsten mal was ich aber gut fand
ist die Induktionsplatte da hat ich
damals so ein bisschen meine Bedenken
aber durch das richtige Kochgeschirr
finde ich kann man auf jeden Fall eine
Induktionsplatte nehmen denn ich merke
das jetzt immer bei meiner Mama wenn ich
bei ihr bin und am zerankochfeld koche
ohne Induktion dauert es einfach alles
viel zu lange und ich bin jetzt eben
schon dran gewöhnt an dieses schnelle
kochen und möchte es gerne auch
weiterhin so behalten natürlich was ich
damals auch schon angesprochen habe
waren die Griffe und ich wollte schon
immer eine grifflose Küche haben und mir
wurde dann zu diesen Griffen hier
geraten die man im Prinzip nicht so sehr
sieht im nachhinein ärgert es mich
natürlich sehr weil ich eine sehr große
staubfläche habe und die eigentlich
vermeiden wollte und was ich fast noch
schlimmer finde die Verletzungsgefahr
denn die Griffe sind so dass die Ecken
wirklich sehr scharfkantig sind und ich
habe mir da echt schon ein paar Hosen
auch dran kaputt gemacht weil ich immer
mit dem Knie hängen geblieben bin und
hatte plötzlich ein riesen Loch im Knie
Samira hat sich da auch schon sehr oft
angestoßen und das würde ich heute
einfach ein bisschen anders machen ich
habe damals auch nicht so viel Wert auf
Elektrogeräte gelegt was ich jetzt im
Nachhinein natürlich sehr schade finde
bei den Backöfen z.B musste ich oben die
Heizstäbe mit einem Draht befestigen
weil die einfach immer wieder
runtergeklappt sind ich habe aber
einfach ein bestimmtes Budget gehabt und
habe z.B hier vorne so einen so eine
baröffnung und die habe ich einfach an
Stelle einer Schublade genommen die
Schublade wäre natürlich ein bisschen
günstiger gewesen die baröffnung war ein
bisschen teurer sieht natürlich auch
toll aus aber da bin ich einfach
Kompromisse eingegangen die ich jetzt
heute einfach ein bisschen anders machen
würde und mir stattdessen einfach
bessere Backöfen holen würde weil ich
eben jeden Tag damit Backe in meinem
Video vor 3 Jahren habe ich euch dazu
geraten eure Küche unbedingt in einem
Fachgeschäft vor Ort zu kaufen denn
somit unterstützt ihr nicht nur die
Wirtschaft vor Ort und den Händler vor
Ort sondern es ist auch wirklich gut für
euch denn ihr werdet da wirklich bestens
beraten und ich habe mich jetzt dieses
Mal dazu entschlossen eine Küche beim
musterhausküchenfachgeschäft zu holen
und sie dort planen zu lassen jeder hat
ein musterhausküchenfachgeschäft in der
Nähe und bei mir war es jetzt so ich
habe vor einem Jahr die liebe Claudia
kennengelernt auf einer Veranstaltung in
Berlin auf das Event in Berlin wurde ich
von musterhauskücher direkt eingeladen
jetzt fragt euch wahrscheinlich wie
kamen die denn auf mich und zwar war das
so die haben als Suchbegriff immer Küche
eingegeben bei Google und auch bei
Youtube und sind dann immer bei meinen
Videos gelandet und die haben sich
natürlich gefragt wie schafft die S das
immer oben hier zu sein und deswegen
durfte ich dahin reisen nach Berlin mit
Mat und habe da vor 3000
Familienunternehmen mich vorstellen
dürfen und einfach erzählt was ich mache
und dass sich eben auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal alles um die Themen
Haushalt Familie und Küche dreht und ja
da war auch der exgogle Chef und es war
wirklich eine mega große Veranstaltung
und da habe ich eben unter anderem auch
die liebe Claudia kennengelernt und ihr
Familienunternehmen in Kandel den Ort
kenne ich weil wir dort ganz gerne
Hähnchen essen gehen mit der Familie und
mit Freunden und dann habe ich sie dort
einmal besucht und mir hat auch wirklich
sehr gut gefallen was sie dort alles
anbietet und jetzt war sie vor ein paar
Wochen bei mir zu Hause ich habe ihr
meine jetzige Küche gezeigt habe ihr
auch gezeigt was mir sehr gut gefällt an
ihr und was mir nicht so gut gefällt was
ich gerne optimieren möchte und im
Prinzip weiß sie jetzt was ich brauche
was meine Mama braucht und kann jetzt
auf meine Wünsche und auf meine
Bedürfnisse eingehen und am meisten
gefällt mir dass ich mich jetzt im
Prinzip noch nicht für einen Hersteller
entscheiden muss also die kaudia ist zw
schon mit der Küchenplanung sehr
fortgeschritten weiß auch jetzt schon wo
die Anschlüsse sind wo der Backofen sein
wird aber ich muss mich jetzt noch nicht
entscheiden sondern erst dann wenn ich
weiß was ich brauche und welcher
Hersteller einfach zu meinen
Bedürfnissen passt jetzt habe ich euch
aber so viel von der Claudia erzählt ich
denke ihr wollt sie auch mal sehen
deswegen nehme ich euch jetzt einfach
mal mit nach
Kel
tschüss
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt im Musterhaus
Küchenfachgeschäft frei in Kantel ich
schaue jetzt gleich mal wie weit die
Claudia mit der Küchenplanung ist aber
vorher schauen wir uns gemeinsam und
paar Küchen an und für dich Ella gibt's
auch eine kleine
[Musik]
Spielecke
wow die Küche gefällt mir mal richtig
gut hallo Sally hi Claudia
schön dich zu sehen schön dass du da
bist ja danke echt schön also ich habe
gerade schon deine Küche bewundert und
die gefällt mir richtig gut die habe ich
letztes mal noch gar nicht gesehen nee
das ist unser aktuellstes Modell haben
wir jetzt gerade aufgebaut und eine
weiße Küche hat man ja für dich auch
überlegt die hat jetzt eine Glasfront
eine
mattglasfront und
schön was wir da noch gemacht haben ist
die Arbeitsplatte haben wir
unterleuchtet dadurch hat kriegt sie so
einen schwebenden Charakter und sieht
sehr gemütlich aus genau man hat gleich
so bisschen durch das Licht Atmosphäre
im Raum mit Licht kann man ja
mittlerweile unheimlich viel machen und
hier haben wir noch die massivholzblatte
ergänzt aus unserer Schreinerei haben
wir ja bei dir auch überlegt aus der
Schreinerei noch was dazu zu machen da
haben wir durch das
massivholzende Natürlichkeit und als
Kontrast zu der klaren weißen fronthm es
ist eigentlich eine ganz schöne
Ergänzung doch gefällt mir sehr gut aber
du hast bestimmt noch ein bisschen mehr
oder ja komm mit ich zeig dir noch ein
paar
Sachen bei der Küche ist das Besondere
das ist eine steinfonier Front und
Diemer kombiniert mit dem Altholz das
sieht man auch hier vorne ganz gut aus
der Schreinerei sieht ja auch toll aus
ne wenn man da auch hinlangt hat man
eine schöne Oberfläche genau ganz
individuelle Ausführung und auch
spannende Kombination bei der
Arbeitsplatte ist das Besondere das ist
eine schichtstoffplatte mit
Nanobeschichtung und anti Fingerprint
dass
die genau perfekt für unseren Haushalt
mit Kindern genau mit
ehann
[Musik]
bei der Küche haben wir auch was
besonderes schön viel
Licht ja die Sonne strahlt uns heute an
hier ist ein Schrank mit besonders viel
Stauraum und auch ganz leicht zu
bedienen sehr übersichtlich ja vor allem
hat man da nicht alles so hinten im
Schrank drin sondern kann das schön
vorne holen gell geht nichts
verloren Zugriff sieht super
[Musik]
aus was ich dir jetzt noch zeigen kann
ist hier in der Küche da haben wir eine
schöne starkfier Front von
österreichischen Lieferanten sehr
angenehm von der Haptik und was bei dem
Schrank besonders ist es ist eine
grifflose Küche da hab wir quasi den
elektrischen Türöffner vom
Kühlschrank da versteckt sich ein
Kühlschrank genau sehr schön auch ein
ziemlich großer gut geeignet für eine
Familie wo immer viel geht in der Küche
und wenn du das jetzt zchst einfach dann
ganz normal dann zieht er sich wieder zu
okay sehr
[Musik]
schön du hast großen Külschrank gewüncht
da zeig ich dir jetzt noch mal ein
Modell kommt deinen Bedürfnissen noch
näher weil das ist eins der
Premiumklasse sozusagen der hat
verschiedene Klimazonen und auch
unheimlich viel Stauraum links quasi in
Gefrierfach rechts der Kühlschrank und
da ist sind noch die
Eiswürfelbereiter genau produziert und
außen kann man dann das Glas hinstellen
und kann das einfach abgreifen sehr
[Musik]
schön jetzt muss ich dir noch was ganz
aktuelles zeigen ja die muldenlüfter die
haben so bisschen den Markt derobert
mittlerweile gibt's sie von vielen
Herstellern und das ist jetzt einer von
Siemens der ganz neu rausgekommen ist
mhm was bei denen ganz gut ist da wird
der Dampf dort abgesaugt wo er entsteht
okay ist ganz gut aber praktisch so
mitten auf der Arbeitsfläche also mitten
auf dem Herd was passiert wenn jetzt mir
z.B das Nudelwasser überläuft ja läuft
ja alles rein oder gar kein Problem da
kann ich den erstmal den die Abdeckung
die Abdeckung runternehmen dann nehme
ich das raus hier okay und hier ist dann
quasi der Abzug drin den kann ich in die
Spülmaschine stellen und das kann ich
ganz normal re reinigen und da ist auch
noch mal ein Überlauf
Rille okay soass
auch wenn mehr Wasser reinläuft ist es
kein
Problem ma halt auch nicht dieser
störende
dunstabzugshau überm Kopf g genau genau
ja man kann viel klarer planen man stößt
sich den Kopf nicht gerade mal so groß
ist wie du oder wie viele Menschen
aktuell ist es einfach ja viel
wohnlicher insgesamt okay also du mur
hat zwar nie ein Problem damit aber wenn
ich bei meiner Mama bin ich stoß mir den
Kopf bei ihr immer an ja das glaube ich
[Musik]
sieht ja auch interessant aus was ist
das hier ja das ist super das ist ein
tepagnaki da kann ich quasi alles drauf
machen was man anbrätt kann Rührei drauf
machen Spiegelei ich kann Fleisch
anbraten skambis okay das heißt ich kann
für Murat auch ein bisschen suuk
anbraten ach schön und die Reinigung ist
wahrscheinlich auch ganz leicht ne ja
geht super ma dann einfach noch bisschen
lässt noch mal bisschen aufkochen wenn
was angebrannt ist und dann kann man es
mit dem
Zeba abwischen im Haushaltstuch
Abwischen der gehört zu mir ja ist echt
interessant hier haben wir z.B Backofen
was bei dem Backofen besonders ist der
hat ein sehr großes garraumvumen was für
dich ja auch wichtig ist man kann mal
größere Torten ma natürlich auch ein
Braten oder
was er auch hat man kann hier
verschiedene Gerichte garen mhm also
Kuchen z.B Brot und Brötchen okay das
ist schon
voreingestelltch genau und ich kann mir
im Prinzip suchen was ich brauche wenn
ich jetzt
z.B Fleisch machen möchte habe ich
verschiedene Möglichkeiten dann kann ich
dir das Gewicht vom Fleisch eingeben
kann das anpassen und dann macht er mir
pro Fleisch im Prinzip Vorschlag er
brätt an und er geht fertig im Prinzip
mit mit dem abschließenden freäunden
sehr schön was er auch hat sind die
Teleskop dreifach Teleskop Vollauszüge
dass ich
meine Gerichte voll ausziehen kann und
kann sie noch mal bestreichen ohne dass
ich mir die Finger verbrenne okay dann
haben wir die pizzastufe pizzastufe ist
beispielsweise doppelte Unterhitze dann
schmeckt die wenn dadurch gart wie aus
dem Steinofen gemacht wir von unten und
oben wird normal gegart und hat ein
perfektes Ergebnis cool hier haben wir
jetzt mal eine Collage gelegt von den
verschiedenen
frontmöglichkeiten das ist jetzt eine
betonfront gespachtelte Front hat so
bisschen den coolenlässigen Style wir
wollen ja für die Showküche das ist so
so Bedingungen quasi und haben wir
überlegt ob man das da bisschen betonen
als Kontrast könnte man jetzt weiß
nehmen da mal noch ein Holzelement dabei
aus der Schreinerei da können wir noch
ein bisschen spielen und dann haben wir
ja auch überlegt ob man vielleicht was
mit Tafellack machen oder so das da
haben wir noch ein Muster das geht dann
wieder in die Richtung dann können wir
mit Wiederholungen arbeiten quasi undten
hell dunkelkontrasten was ganz
interessant ist ist die
Keramikoberfläche die ist das ist die
hitzebeständigste Oberfläche von den
Arbeitsplatten die es aktuell am Markt
gibt das heiß ich kann da auch mal ein
heißen Topf mein Backblech abstellen
ohne ständig Topflappen drunter zu
machen genau du kannst auch mal Topf
rüberziehen auf der Arbeitsplatte
passiert nichts super ja natürlich sehr
praktisch bei mir genau vor allem mit
den wenn du was aus dem Backofen holst
die Kuchenformen die sind ja schon sehr
he passier arbeitsche absolut nicht nee
genau da brauchst du keine Bedenken zu
haben ist auch Keramik ja das ist auch
mit glasanteilen dekton nennt sich das
was hier ganz schön ist sind die a dann
die feinen drin das wenn man das jetzt
zusammen verarbeiten wird hät man so
eine monolitische tonin tonwikung das
wäre jetzt auch ganz schön bei der Insel
und bei der Rückwand mit den mit der
Spüle können man dann wieder gucken dass
man vielleicht was anderes macht dass
man da bisschen mit Kontrasten arbeitet
richtig schön al ich glaube hier wird
jeder fündig ja musamit gibt's
mittlerweile sehr sehr viele was das
Herz begehrt von günstig bis exklusiv
und ganz wichtig ist dass man nach
seinem Bauch hört dass man seinen
individuellen Stil verfolgt es gibt
nicht im Moment eigentlich immer so man
muss das und das haben sondern man muss
gucken was gefällt mir wo fühle ich mich
W was passt zu meinem Raum was passt zu
meinem Umfeld das ist ganz wichtig und
wenn wir so vorgehen und uns da den Weg
Ben dann finden wir bestimmt das
Richtige für dich okay denke
auch jetzt hab wir ganz schön viel
gesehen ich glaube ihr habt auch ein
paar Eindrücke gewonnen und ich habe
jetzt natürlich noch die Qual der Wahl
und muss mich für eine Küche entscheiden
wohl oder übel und vielleicht könnt ihr
mir ja mal schreiben wie eure Traumküche
aussieht und falls ihr auch eine Küche
gerade plant dann schaut doch mal in
eineem musterhausküchenfachgeschäft in
eurer Nähe vorbei die haben nämlich auch
gerade eine richtig tolle Aktion genau
wer im Moment eine Küche in ein
Musterhaus Küchenfachgeschäft kauft
bekommt diese Küchenmaschine dazu
geschenkt und damit man auch die
passenden Rezepte hat gibt's auch noch
das Rezeptbuch mit meinen
lieblingstorten gratis mit dazu und ich
würde jetzt mal sagen Claudia jetzt
haben wir hier so viele Küchen gesehen
und ich habe ein paar Zutaten mit dabei
lass uns noch ein Kuchen backen ja das
ist super okay bis bald tschüss und ich
halte euch auf dem laufenden bis
[Musik]
bald
qu i for
you break it
into
long before
I
[Musik]
US
hold don't give
[Musik]
up
break
down to
far in the dark
don't myish heart
don't
Magic
make work
[Musik]
alough
h
[Musik]
make